Spring cleaning has
taken a whole new meaning
as millions of people
stay in to curb the spread
of the coronavirus and
realize just how dirty
everything in their home is.
But with so much
misinformation floating around
about what works and what
doesn't, what can you do?
I got a little help over
Skype from Mikhail Varshavski,
better known as Doctor
Mike, to get the facts
about how to keep our stuff clean.
- Well, the first thing you need
to do is when you walk
inside from the outdoors,
you need to disinfect your body.
It doesn't mean taking a full shower,
it means washing your
hands very thoroughly,
taking your shoes off,
leaving them by the door,
because that's the easiest way to bring in
those germs from the outside in.
We don't want that to happen.
How do we fight it?
Washing our hands. And then the thing
that our hands touch most,
especially nowadays, are our cellphones.
So we need to disinfect these bad boys
when we come from the outdoors as well.
Because we wash our hands, but
we were just touching this,
so all the viruses, all the bacteria,
is still alive on the cellphone.
In fact, Apple just put out a
great release on how to clean
your cellphones properly
so you don't damage them.
- Looking at Apple's guidelines
for how to clean my iPhone,
I'm 100% okay doing
what I have been doing,
but probably should be doing more often,
which is using a wipe
and just gently wiping
the exterior surfaces.
Now I just need to know which
of these cleaning products
to actually use on other
things around the house.
- If you're going to be using
any kind of bleach product,
it is recommended that you do
it in an open-air environment.
So either you open up a window
or you do it in a well ventilated room,
because the bleach can aerosolize
and irritate your eyes.
There are products that can
disinfect without bleach.
That being said, there
is no miracle product
that's better than the other.
Ready the labels very carefully.
They'll tell you which one is
a truly disinfecting product.
In fact, if you look on some
of the products you'll see
that coronavirus is on the list of things
that these disinfectants treat
because this novel coronavirus is not
the first coronavirus we've seen.
Coronavirus is simply a strain of viruses
that cause all sorts of
respiratory conditions.
I've never noticed this
on products before,
so I went looking at some
of the disinfecting products
that I have around my house.
And these handy wipes explicitly say
"the human coronavirus."
I've also been using these wipes on a lot
of other surfaces around
my house like doorknobs,
light switches, faucets, remote controls.
- There's been a couple
of research articles
that came out testing how
long this virus survives
in different temperatures, humidities,
on different surfaces, even in the air.
And copper seems to be
one of those surfaces
that the virus lives a very
short amount of time on
when you compare it to
something like plastic or steel.
Why is that problematic?
Well, the majority of
our household products,
our mice, our keyboards,
they're made of plastic.
So it's easy, that if
your hands are dirty,
to have it live for a long
period of time on these products.
- So my wipes are going
to be a permanent addition
to my work-from-home setup.
Also because my coworkers
like to walk on my keyboard
and interact with me at my
dining table-slash-desk.
At least I don't have to worry
about taking these two out
for a walk and bringing
the coronavirus back in.
- There's been a lot of talk
about pets being carriers
of this virus, and while
we haven't seen evidence
of them truly being sickened by this virus
and then getting their owners sick,
what we have seen is pets acting
like a surface contaminant.
So if your walking outside and
someone asks to pet your dog,
respectfully ask them to
practice proper social distancing
so that they don't leave the
virus on your dog's hair,
so that when you come
in and start petting it
now the virus is on your hands.
That's a strong recommendation.
Also, very simple, when you're coming
in from the outdoors, wipe
your dogs' or cats' paws
so that they don't
bring the virus indoors.
The virus does live a much
shorter time on surfaces
in the environment where there's sun
because the sun is natures
disinfectant with its UV rays.
But that being said,
there's still a possibility
that someone could have sneezed,
your dog or cat could have stepped on that
and then bring it inside the house.
So practice proper social distancing.
Clean them just like
you're cleaning yourself,
and you'll be able to be safe.